>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR GENERATIONS CALIFORNIA
SYMBOLIZED EVERYTHING THAT WAS
FANTASTIC AND GREAT ABOUT
AMERICA.
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACE IN
THE WORLD.
SNOW CAPPED MOUNTAINS,
PRISTINE BEACHES AND LUSH
VALLEYS BUT MORE THAN A
VACATION SPOT.
THEY SUPPORTED THE BIGGEST
MIDDLE CLASS IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAD A GLEAMING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY MADE THE AMERICAN DREAM A
REALITY.
NOW THEY ARE KNOWN FOR A
DIFFERENT SET OF IMAGES.
NEEDLES AND FECES IN THE
STREET, DYING MIDDLE CLASS AND
HIGHEST RATE.
CALIFORNIA IS STILL A SYMBOL
BUT IT IS A SYMBOL OF
EVERYTHING THAT HAS GONE
WRONG.
TRACE JOINS US WITH THE LATEST
FROM THE ONCE GOLDEN STATE.
TRACE?
>> FOR GAVIN NEWSOM IT'S
HUMMING ALONG NICELY.
HE SAYS, "AMERICA IN 2019 IS
CALIFORNIA IN THE 1990s.
THE SCENE ROW PHOBIA,NATE
TIFF.
I -- XENOPHOBIA, NATIVEISM.
THE FEAR OF THE OTHER.
HE SAID WE ARE WORKING AND
DEMOCRATS ARE INWINNING
DEMOCRATS ARE WNWINNING
DEMOCRATS ARE WININNING
DEMOCRATS ARE WINNINING
DEMOCRATS ARE WINNINGNG
DEMOCRATS ARE WINNING NOW.
SOMEONE FORGET TO TELL HIM 40%
OF HIS PEOPLE LIVE NEAR
POVERTY AND THE HIGHEST TAXES
AND COST OF LIVING ISN'T
GIVING THEM A LEG UP.
JULY 1, THEY WILL PAY SIX MORE
FOR GAS TAXES.
THAT IS ON TOP OF HAVING THE
HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY BEGIN BACKGROUND CHECKS
FOR BUYING BULLETS TO QUICK LE
RETURN INFORMATION ON FELONY
RESTRICTIONS.
NON-CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS CAN
NO LONGER BUY AMMUNITION HERE
PERIOD.
THEY HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
BATHROOMS THAN IS SYRIAN REFEW
GEES WHICH IS APPARENT TO
EVERYONE IN L.A. AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
BUT PUTTING IN MORE BATHROOMS
WOULD COST $57 MILLION A YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL LIKE HOMELESS
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
WINNING EITHER.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
THE CALIFORNIA WAGES WAR ON
THE OWN MIDDLE CLASS THAT
TRIES TO BUILD MEN'S ROOM THAT
COST AS MUCH AS HOUSES THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T SEEM A
PROBLEM WITH THE STATE AS YOU
HEARD.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MIDDLE
EAST FAMILIES FLED AND
CONTINUE TO FLEE EVERY YEAR.
MEANWHILE, GAVIN NEWSOM IS
TRAVELING TO CENTRAL AMERICA
TELLING HIS CITIZENS THE